è la tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo tornati su
siamo veramente tornati su dopo surgeon
simulator non potevo non fare ti
consigliamo di giocare a the bride con
un gamepad proprio come un ottimo tosti
imburrato mi ero dimenticato la
musichetta stupida che parte all'inizio
del video va bene se lo so io e brad
ragazzi un gioco che si gioca con un
gamepad ci sono a chi dlc c'è starci
wars dal tono ancora fatto stars wars
non molto tempo fa in una galassia
neanche tanto lontana e non è affatto
ufficiale è chiaramente una parodia
comunque dai lasciamo perdere però sto
leggendo il mio addio stars wars
episodio iv una nuova pagnotta dopo la
distruzione della pompa di benzina alle
ultime briciole la flotta di belle
vengono intercettate lungo la rotta però
state en nell'estremo momento del
bisogno pan solo uno eletto più
nient'altro va bene così fa bene anzola
era bellissimo giocare c'è una cosa vedo
però forse l'avevo già va bene va bene
torna almeno basta mi va bene qui ci
sono ancora i miei salvata ma come fa
ricordassi tutti i miei salvaguardato 40
c o giocata sta roba a dalida storia la
facciamo il primo episodio che era era
un casino ve lo assicuro diventa un
toast allora questa è la storia vela
narro io e la storia di questo pezzo di
pane quello che io devo fare arrivare al
tostapane è una cosa che non ha senso
voi direte se noi ci giochiamo c lo
stesso contatto che veramente sto
giocando con borja vacca non posso
rimanere per terra perché se rimango
porterà muoio
ok perché ovviamente un tosto e muore
quando si sporca e se stai per terra e
pieno di microbi 80 sempre cento di
commestibilità siamo arrivati fin qua va
bene prof
le formiche sono le formiche la ritraeva
blasi stupido
vai vai vai avanti e va avanti va avanti
credetemi che più ai avanti e più
difficile cioè che sta ancora non è
niente e come avevo fatto a partito di
questi progressi sto gioco che un casino
vero la madonna vivo la mia vita un
quarto di marmellata al secondo
no no no mai nella vita nel mondo dove
sono finito
by sono fatta no no no no non l'ho mai
aperto la scatola mi ha salvato e ci
voleva tanto lavati effettivamente un
tosto e lavato con il sapone per piatti
non è commestibile propria è venuto in
mente dopo dai vari noi possibile dai
raga gran faty spiderman cinese ci siamo
quasi praticamente non lo so il
tostapane li devo nomi come devo
buttarmi fin lì però credo che stride
uno slancio 200c euro vai ma tu vai
ragazzi allora rimane la la cosa finale
da fare che quella di spostarsi che non
è facile come credete
ma come faccio ad entrare con che fisica
dai non è complicato un tostapane
maledizione entra c o oggi e su quanti
problemi per trento stampa ne vedo
uscire io da solo vesco che non escono k
perfetto tosto giocherà sta roba ha
messo una famiglia incredibile chiamo la
pizzeria fermi tutti io comunque
registro sembra ora dicendo poi gioco a
giochi dove c'è da mangiare quindi in
qualche modo
[Musica]
e aggiungo anche per la gioia di gianpi
tech che sto utilizzando il mio form per
chiamare la pizzeria
proprio capite riguarderà posso avere
un'informazione solo al volo da fare la
pizza carciofini sarebbe possibile fare
anche delle aggiunte perché sono le
acciughe
si va dai ragazzi giorno dopo
bisogna fare qua se vi dico come devo
tostarlo in salotto il pane non ci
credete devo far cadere la palla da
bowling sul televisore il televisore
esplode può sottostare il toast sopra il
televisore esploso prossima dal divano
che ve le scarpate che vedo per terra
tira un po di toast e scarpate ammessi
sincero
porca vacca che schifo ma nella regola
dei cinque secondi se non rimane 5
secondi per terra ancora buono non c'ero
non esiste st regolati ha detto che la
regola dei cinque secondi esiste in
realtà e bear grylls che si mangia anche
i topi
no no coke e la portiamo togliti scatola
stupida e vabbè veloce che per di
aderenza veloce veloce frattempo però
c'è anche incastrare scuro che sono più
sporche le mensole che per terra però va
bene ok perfetto ragazzi ci siamo
dovrei riuscire a spingere la palla da
bowling sul televisore posso perfetto
sta cuocendo solo una parte perché devo
facevo da tutte due parti il gioco più
difficile che abbia mai visto perché per
fare una mappa ci metteva un video
intero che sono già fatte due sono alla
terni volta stato se già sporco come
cosa ma come perché si e 30 per cento di
successo perché eletto e spagna del suo
letto e spara ma se io bagno sul letto
ogni giorno che quarti peli ci sta sul
sole tour cane cane un licantropo maraga
non ci arriverò mai più si va beh
basta quanti avete vomitato sui muri o
un fenomeno così così no non cadere
bravo perfetto per caramelle nelle bio
ora come sono attaccate bene e va beh
non mi sa che io non ho capito se mio
staccano le caramelle ma mi pare di no
però il muro poi sporto quindi 4 e vabbè
è crollato pure quadro posso usare il
quadro raga non ci ho pensato mai credo
sia il ferro da stiro perché altro non
vedo tanto posso usare il quadro come
all and nice
spero sia il ferro perché non ho idea se
no
eccolo lì se però per cento di
commestibilità tra l'altro come ho vinto
zero per cento di convertibilità o fatto
zero per cento di come essi vita hanno
tanto non ho visto anche come l'ho persa
non ho assolutamente visto come perso la
commestibilità però l'ho persa tutta
direi di fare l'ultimo ragazzi che il
bagno il bagno neanche questo mi ricordo
si vede che per arrivare qua ci ho messo
una vita e ho voluto rimuovere i ricordi
che sei brutto accordo o liti maledetta
mar me la cosa ci fa la marmellata nel
bagno ragazzi ma me lo spiegate voi
l'esatta funzione di una papera di gomma
no non servire anni e ve la do io
tagliargli la testa tre volte
adesso se riesco a passare sopra la
porta in teoria dovrei essere anche
quasi a buon punto
no no no no no non ho mai fatto non è
vero nel mondo che forse forse ci
arriviamo c'è anche il termosifone raga
ragazzo non così arrivato incredibile
meno male che ho parlato grande questa
banca un bug no chi dice no agli
attacchi anti fumo donna
ok ora il termosifone ringraziando il
cielo ovvero per cento di commestibilità
di nuovo due i livelli finiti con zero
per cento di commestibilità
vabbè ragazzi io direi che possiamo più
tranquilla il pali nella vita è
essenziale soprattutto quello sporco io
vado ad haga che ciò la pizza con la
furia che mi aspetta però che mi fanno
anche un po schifo
cioè mi fanno veramente schifo infatti
non la mangiano mai e se volete
informazioni riguardanti il mio phone
come sempre in dischi
se ne trovate il link con tutte le
informazioni di cui avete bisogno
mi piace questo genere si vede e non ci
vediamo da ragazzo
[Musica]